- Well, I have to ask,
did any of the coaches try to
take advantage of my absence?
- (laughs) I mean, their
biggest thing was they refused
to admit that you didn't feel good,
they were like, "She's on a beach.
She needs a break.
I was like 18 jobs.
She wanted a tan. She's gone."
And I was like
"I'm sure she'd rather be
doing that than being sick."
But other than that, they, they love you.
They really love you.
So they didn't talk any
crap at all. (laughs)
- Oh man, I bet that all
came from Shelton too.
Um, we, I was not on vacation.
I was in hell with a sinus infection
but we were in constant
contact though all weekend.
I think people are
probably going to see you
on your phone a lot and think
you're just like texting
like your friends or something.
But we were texting the
entire time on this show
and I don't know if you know
people are going to know that or not
so I wanted to say that
but did I help you or
hurt you by doing that?
- Oh God, I, you helped me so much.
And for reference, for everyone listening
like Kelly called me at
7:00 PM Nashville time.
And they were shooting the
next day at 1:00 PM in LA.
And, and so I
I fully went back to college,
like on the flight over
she sent me all of the blind auditions,
she sent me everything about
like everyone on her team,
what she loved, what she was looking for,
and so as soon as I landed you and I got
to talk and you just like downloaded all
of your incredible
knowledge and you were like
"This is what I love about this person.
This is what I want to see."
And so when I got in
the chair, I was like,
"First of all where's that seat warmer
that you were telling me
about because it is cold."
- [Kelly] I, I told you!
I was like, "Look for the seat warmer.
Your butt is going to be so cold."
And I wear Spanx girl, I'm all covered up
but I understand it's you.
I'm cold! You had to be dying.
But can you, can you tell everyone like
about this week's episode?
Cause I wasn't there.
So you would know.
- Honestly, it's, it's so
crazy because obviously
there's great talent on a
show called "The Voice".
Like the voices are crazy
but when you're actually sitting there
in the room and you're
watching these, these artists
some of them are like really seasoned
and then some of them are really early on
in like discovering their instrument.
You're watching them, just,
I just had goosebumps most
of the time, just the talent
is really crazy this season.
Um, and the one thing you asked
me was to keep the rivalry
with Blake,
and so I really took that to heart.
So those are the two
things that I can tell you
is that the talent's really great,
the choices were really hard,
but we talked about it and Blake
probably hates me. (laughs)
- Oh my God.
I was so excited about the dad thing.
I can't even tell you.
I was like, "Oh my God,
she's my favorite."